October 10th marks world day against the
death penalty a call to abolish capital
punishment Around the Globe last year 18
countries including the United States
executed people China is among those
that refused to publish data on the
death penalty that makes it almost
impossible to know exactly how many
people were executed worldwide
what we do know is that Iran has one of
the highest Global execution rates at
least 314 people were executed there in
2021 that's according to Amnesty
International that's up 28 percent on
the year before
three of those executed in Iran were
under 18 at the time of their alleged
crimes
many more people in Iran have been
sentenced to die on our waiting
execution DW's Persian service has
spoken to one person who can't be
identified he's received the death
penalty but is currently on bail and
does not know what will happen next
you know when you get the death sentence
everything changes from that moment on
it seems that everyone is different
everything was going very slowly
it's like my brain didn't want to and
couldn't accept it I was in denial
I couldn't believe that I received a
death sentence
after that my illness relapsed in prison
they did not give me my medicine at all
they didn't give me medicine until I was
very sick
they had to take me to the hospital with
two prison guards
do you know what one of the guards said
in front of me he said he's been given a
death sentence and he's going to be
executed quickly so why are they taking
him to the hospital what is the point
when my mother was told the verdict she
was at work and She fainted whenever my
parents called me in prison they were
sobbing they both broke
and for more we're joined by Mahmoud
Amiri mogadam he's a professor of
neuroscience at the University of Oslo
he's also the director and co-founder of
the NGO Iran human rights which monitors
human rights violations in Iran thank
you very much for being with us now we
just heard from an Iranian who has the
death sentence hanging over their head
you're a neuroscientist can you tell us
what that does to a person
good morning
um well you see the theme of the world
day this year is that penalty a road
paved by torture and as we could hear
also from what
um this prisoners said
life changes completely we have talked
to many death row prisoners they are
traumatized for for the rest of their
life as long as it takes we know the
situation in the on the death row is uh
um a disaster and beside that the
process of being sentenced to that in
Iran very often people are sentenced to
that based on confessions extracted by
torture so so
um I don't think we can actually
understand how it feels to be to be on a
death row
how difficult is it to compile
information about the use of the death
penalty in Iran
well um Iranian authorities Do not
announce all the executions so uh this
morning we published a report showing
that at least
428 people have been executed in Iran so
far in 2022 it's 89 percent increase
authorities announced only 12 percent of
these executions so about 88 percent
have been documented and confirmed by
Iran human rights it's very difficult
but after about 15 years of monitoring
the death penalty we have a broad
Network enabling us to document and to
confirm cases so what we do we we get it
from live
eyewitnesses other prisoners people
within the system families lawyers but
it is difficult and Reporting about that
penalty is illegal and the person doing
that can be sentenced to heavy prison or
even death sentence
okay I just want to repeat that figure
you gave us 428 executions so far this
year you're calling that an 89 increase
on the year before
um assuming that this information is
correct why would you why do you think
that executions in Iran are increasing
to that degree
this is the the number that we have
managed to confirm through two
independent sources and you see uh our
research of the death penalty Trends in
the last 15 years shows that despite the
fact that most people executed are
charged with the charges like a homicide
or drug trafficking the timing of the
executions are very uh closely related
to political events when the authorities
fear protests they increase the number
of executions so it seems that the
authorities have been expecting protests
in 2022 and and we believe that their
aim has been to create fear in the
society to prevent protests but
obviously they have failed you can also
see in other countries you know the
pictures that we have from daesh Isis
when they took over Syria and Iraq is
the picture of mass executions because
death penalty is the main instrument of
creating fear and political oppression
for any dictator
Professor thank you very much for
talking with us that was Professor
Mahmoud Amiri mogadam director of the
NGO Iran human rights